The planet is Arrakis.
Also known as Dune.
And y’all, it’s a mess.
December of this year, we were supposed to
see the arrival of director Denis Villeneuve’s
interpretation of the 1965 novel Dune, which
had been previously (and rather infamously)
brought to life by David Lynch in 1984, and
again in a three part miniseries on the SyFy
channel in the early 2000s.
Now many sci-fi nerds (including myself) were
both excited and nervous about the new adaptation
directed by Villeneuve, but owing to the ongoing
plague of eternity, the release has been pushed
back to next year.
So in lieu of that, y’all have to use this
video to tide you over.
What is Dune?
Why must the spice flow?
And what is with all the sand?
(I hate sand, it’s coarse and it gets everywhere)
Dune is a 1965 science-fiction novel by American
author Frank Herbert, and is the first installment
of the Dune Saga, which is made up of five
sequels written by Herbert himself and several
subsequent books made under the collaboration
of Brian Herbert (Frank Herbert’s son) and
writer Kevin J. Anderson.
They are … controversial.
While not an instant bestseller, it was a
massive critical success, with winning both
the Hugo and the Nebula awards in 1966.
Dune itself would eventually be called the
“best selling science fiction book of all
time” in 2003.
Taking place in humanity’s distant future,
the universe is now a feudal interstellar
society in which various noble houses control
planetary fiefs, with the most important being
the desert planet Arrakis.
Ya see, Arrakis is the source of the spice
melange which extends your life, gives you
cool mental abilities, and is essential for
space navigation.
And it absolutely must flow.
You’d think with a planet that important
it would just belong to everyone … but … I
guess they're going for realism
The current galactic ruler, the Emperor Shaddam
IV (4th) is what we would call, an insecure
hater.
He sees how popular this one guy, Duke Leto
Atreides, has gotten and takes advantage of
a blood feud between House Atreides and their
rivals, House Harkonnen, to destroy the Atreides
family.
And so Arrakis, which previously belonged
to the Harkonnens, is given to Duke Leto---with
the intention that he and his family have
move to this sandy, mostly inhospitable planet
in order to protect the spice melange.
What could go wrong!?!
Enter Paul.
Paul is the heir of House Atreides and at
the ripe age of 15 he is ready to be the protagonist
of a science fiction series.
Paul is like the chosen one over 9000.
Prophetic visions?
Yup.
Super rich?
Yes.
Heir of a tragic family?
Superpowered child as the result of a centuries
long breeding program and positioned to be
a prophet to a group of very specifically
coded sand-people?
Specific, but yes.
Spoilers from this point on by the way.
There is an ambush and Paul’s dad is captured,
but he kills himself using a cyanide capsule.
Paul and his mother, Jessica, meet up with
the Fremean, the native population of Dune.
They see Paul as a prophet, and he takes on
the Fremean name Paul Muad'Dib.
After training, getting a new stabby younger
sister, a girlfriend named Chani and taming
the sandworms (massive nightmare snakes that
live in the wild and from whose poop spice
is made), Paul ends up getting revenge for
the death of his father.
After he defeats the Baron Harkonnen (who
is also his surprise grandfather), Paul requests
an audience with Shaddam IV and threatens
to destroy the spice melange, unless he gets
to marry the Emperor's daughter, Princess
Irulan and the Emperor abdicates in favor
of Paul, who is, I reiterate, is a teenager.
Yay?
And that is like the super spark notes summary.
What makes the first book in the saga so compelling
is how it sets up all these themes that Frank
Herbert later deconstructs.
Franklin Patrick Herbert Jr., noted Libra,
had been a pulp writer, photographer, and
journalist before he started doing research
for Dune in 1959.
The endeavor took him six years and more than
400 pages of writing to complete---making
Dune much longer than most science fiction
at the time.
Kevin Mulcahy in “The Prince on Arrakis:
Frank Herbert's dialogue with Machiavelli”
explains that
“Herbert was writing at the height of the
Cold War.
From the conception of Dune to its publication,
a presidential campaign centered around fears
of a "missile gap"; [...] Read in their historical
context, Dune and (to a lesser extent) its
sequels are subversive texts.[...].
Herbert dramatizes in Dune an unpleasant political
truth: people cannot free themselves of Machiavellian
leaders until they first free themselves of
their desire to be led.”
Jennifer Simkins, an English teacher in New
South Wales, Australia, also points out that
the Dune novels “suggest that blind acceptance
of social structures, and the mythic patterns
that inform them, leads to the intellectual
stagnation of humankind.
[...] For Herbert, SF is a mode that “helps
us understand what it means to be human”
by examining established myths.”
The Dune saga highlights Herbert’s evergoing
concern with leadership.
He had always expressed that the first book
and the character of Paul was meant to examine
human tendency to follow charismatic leaders.
Except you don’t particularly get that element
until the second book Dune Messiah, which
puts the D in deconstruction.
You see, in the first book, Paul hijacks the
Fremen’s religion in order to get power
and revenge, which is like yay white boy power
fantasy pew pew.
However, it soon becomes a power that Paul
cannot control.
As a result, when we open Dune Messiah, we
are told that the Fremen started a jihad in
Paul's name across the galaxy that kills (flips
book open) sixty billion people across the
known universe.
Colonization is bad, m’kay.
One of Paul’s visions that he gets from
being special, is that the future of humanity
could go down a path where it will stagnate
and destroy itself.
Thus, Paul thinks that the only way to prevent
this future of eventual human extinction is
to engender such oppressive horrible leadership
that humanity will never follow a leader again.
Sounds legit.
His not official wife, Chani, dies leaving
behind a pair of chosen one TWINS named Luke
and Leia … ahem, I mean Leto II and Ghanima.
And when this happens, he goes into a state
of despair and pretty much abdicates his power
because he can’t be full Vader.
Also, that is shade for Star Wars not Dune
just so we're clear.
Children of Dune, the third book in what we
could call the first Dune trilogy, sets up
the next phase of the series with a new “protagonist”
in Paul’s son, Leto II.
Both of his children have similar powers to
him, but it is Leto who is destined to become
the God Emperor and he does so by being as
evil as he needs to be in order to ensure
the survival of the world.
So let's talk about Paul, the “hero” of
our story, at least at first.
One of the things that is often debated is
if Paul would fall under what you’d call
a “white savior” character.
In many genres, including science fiction,
there is this trope of a white (or white adjacent
person) coming into Black or iindigenous communities
(or in this case, black and indigenous coded),
and becoming their leader by doing what they
already do, but better.
Paul is both.
A “white savior” played straight in the
original Dune, but a deconstruction in the
later books.
In Dune Messiah he compares himself to Hilter
at one point saying: “He killed more than
six million.
Pretty good for those days...
Statistics: at a conservative estimate, I've
killed sixty-one billion, sterilized ninety
planets, completely demoralized five hundred
others.
I've wiped out the followers of forty religions…”
Everything about his character is set up to
be this noble hero who wants to do good, but
his visions are a trap.
Paul does not want to subject the world to
living under a human god and that is criticized
by some in text as being weak, but often,
as is the case with Dune especially, just
because the text says one thing doesn’t
mean we are meant to take it as such.
Especially considering that his son ends up
turning into a giant human/sandworm hybrid
with only a human face and two t-rex arms.
This physical transformation highlights a
point brought up again in Mulcahy’s, piece
“Herbert's Dune novels demonstrate the inevitable
consequences of political manipulation [...[ One
cannot use others without being tainted; people
cannot accede to their own exploitation without
surrendering some of their humanity.”
Paul’s fate is ultimately to be killed by
one of his own acolytes who doesn’t recognize
him--a kind of poetic irony.
Simkins later explains that:
“The depiction of Paul in Dune as a stereotypical
hero activates the reader’s awareness of
the hero schema before the dangers of absolute
rule are illuminated in the sequels.
Herbert explains: “Dune was set up to imprint
on you the reader, a superhero.
I wanted you…
totally involved with that superhero…
And then I wanted to show what happens”
Herbert is both addressing this imperialistic
mindset, but also using it as the basis of
a plan that is supposed to lead the world
into “salvation”, all the while asking
if any of this maneuvering is worth it.
Would things have ended differently if Paul
had just gotten revenge for his father’s
death and left it there?
In my opinion, I think that Herbert is using
Paul’s story to show how these ideas are
toxic and corrosive, with Leto’s transformation
being a physical manifestation of that.
I mean Leto’s plan is to repress humanity
for thousands of years, so that when he dies,
they yeet into the stars and beyond.
Which is basically the same plan as a parent
in a fairytale who puts their child in a tower
rather than just say “hey don’t touch
spinning wheels.”
Or it's like how, after WWII ended, everyone
looked at each other and all agreed, "let's
never have an authoritarian again."
Yeah.
There are also still issues with the way that
the Fremen are used and they become weapons.
Because, despite the text being critical of
that—it doesn’t give them any more humanity.
They remain cyphers.
I think David M. Higgins, Speculative Fiction
Editor for the Los Angeles Review of Books,
put it best, although a tad bit harsher than
me, when he said:
“...Herbert essentially offers a critique
of territorial imperialism while upholding
the axioms of capitalist accumulation that
motivate modern imperial exploits in the first
place[…] Herbert offers a Western audience
a way to have their cake and eat it too: readers
are invited to distance themselves from identification
with imperial oppressors and to identify with
decolonizing nationalists overcoming the tyranny
of imperialism.
Tea.
Dune is hard to adapt because it is just the
beginning of a much larger story.
We have only touched on the first three books
in this video and it still has encompassed
enough for a whole semester of Philosophy
101.
A filmmaker who sees Paul as a savior can’t
really comprehend the fullness of the story.
In some ways that is the trap of Dune.
Only seeing the surface level entertainment
that is meant to deliver these intense messages:
As Herbert himself once said: “If you want
to get anything across, you have to be entertaining
first.
If you start standing on a street corner,
people will tune you out.
[...]But analogues give you a marvelous device
for getting past that screening system, because
people can be caught up in the drama of the
story, be deep into the problems of it.
Then later on, much later on, they say, Oh,
my God, he was talking about this!"
And they come out of it with a brand new view
of what's happening in their world.”
At least you hope so anyway.
Dune is an iconic work of science-fiction
and while we should be critical of it and
discuss the ways in which it is dated, there
is no denying that it has a huge cultural
impact on the genre and asked some really
compelling questions, even if it didn’t
always deliver on the answers.
The spice … must flow.